[Aplausos]
[Música]
noruega es un país famoso por su clima
extremo con largos días de sol o en
verano largos días de noche en invierno
y sobre todo mucho frío
también es conocido por su enorme estado
del bienestar como todo buen país
nórdico también por sus fiordos y tal
vez por encima de todo por el salmón
ahumado
y ojo que no es ninguna tontería la
industria pesquera noruega es una de las
más modernas y más importantes de todo
el mundo sin embargo aún con todo en los
últimos años lo que más se está haciendo
notar es la apuesta noruega por el medio
ambiente especialmente en la lucha
contra el cambio climático y amigos
donde mejor podemos ver toda esta
apuesta es probablemente en el sector
del coche eléctrico veréis noruega tiene
el mercado de coches eléctricos más
desarrollado de todo el planeta aquí
casi uno de cada dos coches que se vende
es un coche eléctrico o al menos un
híbrido pero eso no es todo para 2025 es
decir dentro de nada el gobierno de
noruega quiere que en este país no se
vendan ni más coches de gasolina ni más
coches diésel solo eléctricos e híbridos
cuesta imaginarlo verdad hablamos de
toda una revolución tras más de 100 años
de monopolio del motor de combustión sus
días hoy están llegando a su fin o al
menos en este país aquí la fiebre por lo
eléctrico llega hasta los barcos dos
empresas están
dando un proyecto conocido como el tesla
de los mares para poner a navegar el
primer barco autónomo que funciona
también con baterías eléctricas el
primer hard and beer clan el nombre
formal de este proyecto está previsto
que comienza a navegar a finales de 2018
ahora bien puede que os estáis
preguntando cuál es el secreto de
noruega cómo diantres ha conseguido este
país que los coches eléctricos sean tan
populares es que acaso los noruegos
tienen una conciencia especial bueno
puede que haya algo de factor cultural
en todo esto pero a decir verdad la
realidad es un poco menos idealista la
clave amigos de todo este boom del coche
eléctrico está sobre todo en los
elevados incentivos con los que el
gobierno lleva años apoyando esta
industria fijaos en noruega cuando
quieres comprarte un coche si eliges un
eléctrico te ahorras en impuestos
básicamente una fortuna por ejemplo el
líbano tienes que pagar lo que cuidado
no es poca cosa es del 25% ni tampoco el
impuesto de matriculación
impuestos adicionales el resultado
atentos según un reciente estudio por
ejemplo un test la s que costaría unos
140 mil dólares si tuviera que pagar
todos los impuestos que pagan los coches
de gasolina gracias a los incentivos
viene a salir por unos 70 mil es decir
el ahorro es del 50 por ciento no está
mal verdad por si fuera poco entre otros
muchos beneficios
estos coches tampoco tienen que pagar
los peajes en las carreteras ni los
parquímetros vamos en otras palabras
así cualquiera verdad por cierto en este
país casi toda la electricidad es de
origen hidroeléctrico es decir hablamos
de electricidad barata y limpia por eso
con todas estas políticas verdes que
hemos visto y algunas otras el gobierno
noruego espera reducir en un 40% las
emisiones de co2 en los próximos años la
mismísima constitución noruega en su
artículo 110 se preocupa del medio
ambiente todos tienen derecho a
disfrutar de un medio ambiente que
asegure la salud y de una naturaleza
cuya capacidad
productiva y diversidad sean preservadas
los recursos naturales serán utilizados
partiendo de consideraciones a largo
plazo y universales que salvaguarden
este derecho también para generaciones
venideras artículo 110 de la
constitución de noruega sin embargo
amigos no es oro todo lo que reluce
noruega es un país muy rico con un
estado del bienestar enorme pero con un
ligero problemilla o al menos una
característica que pone furiosos a los
miembros de greenpeace hablamos de la
importancia que la producción de
petróleo tiene en este país pero hasta
dónde llega esa dependencia veámoslo
[Música]
adictos al petróleo
si cogiéramos el delorean de marty mcfly
y nos fuéramos hasta principios del
siglo 20 nos encontraríamos con una
noruega con una economía muy
rudimentaria prácticamente lo que aquí
se hacía era pescar pescar y pescar si
avanzamos en el tiempo aunque la cosa
mejora bastante lo cierto es que a
finales de la década de los 60
noruega no estaba en la lista de los
países más ricos para nada de hecho su
renta per cápita venía a ser teniendo en
cuenta los diferentes niveles de precios
la mitad que la de suiza en 1960 el
nivel de vida en noruega era sobre un 30
o 40 por ciento más bajo que en suecia o
en dinamarca ahora sin embargo el nivel
de vida de noruega es sustancialmente
más alto que en ambos países así que
podemos preguntarnos qué pasó para que
de pronto noruega se convirtiese en uno
de los países más ricos del planeta pues
amigos podemos decir que todo empezó a
cambiar en 1969 en ese año se
descubrieron las primeras grandes
reservas de petróleo y ahí sí a partir
de ese año dio comienzo una
dorada que llevo a este país a
convertirse en uno de los mayores
exportadores mundiales de petróleo y gas
natural si no luego pasó prácticamente
de ser un país más a ser la arabia
saudita de europa como os podéis
imaginar toda esta revolución petrolera
que vivió el país supuso la llegada de
mucho dinero dinero que ayudó a poner en
pie la noruega que todos conocemos hoy
el petróleo y el gas natural juegan un
papel absolutamente clave en este país
en 2016 por ejemplo casi el 40 por
ciento de las exportaciones y más de una
quinta parte de las inversiones tuvieron
su origen en este sector del petróleo y
el gas natural y por supuesto el
gobierno obtiene su parte fijaos según
los años y claro el precio del petróleo
y el gas los ingresos que el gobierno
obtiene de esta industria suponen
aproximadamente entre uno de cada seis y
uno de cada cuatro euros que el gobierno
recauda vamos lo que se dice un pastizal
y más ingresos públicos suelen
y más gasto público un tercio de todos
los noruegos en edad de trabajar no
hacen absolutamente nada más de un
millón de ellos viven del dinero del
estado y todo se debe al petróleo si así
es en buena medida podemos decir que el
modelo noruego que consiste en un estado
del bienestar muy grande y en el control
público de muchas de las grandes
empresas del país tiene que ver mucho
con el petróleo sin embargo amigos la
caída de los precios de esta materia
prima y también de la producción ha
llevado al gobierno a tomar una medida
muy controvertida por primera vez en 20
años el gobierno noruego ha otorgado
nuevas licencias de exploración en
concreto han sido 10 nuevas licencias de
exploración petrolífera en el mar de
bárents en pleno círculo polar artístico
y la verdad este movimiento ha puesto
furiosas a organizaciones ecologistas
como greenpeace que por cierto han
llevado al gobierno a los tribunales
acusándole de violar los acuerdos de
parís de lucha contra el cambio
climático y también de violar su propia
constitución que como hemos visto antes
tiene muy en cuenta la conservación del
medio ambiente el caso es que como veis
parece que el compromiso verde de
noruega tiene algunos límites noruega se
ha propuesto ser un líder mundial en la
acción climática pero la expansión
continua de la producción de petróleo y
gas podría eclipsar los beneficios de
los esfuerzos nacionales de reducción de
emisiones de noruega
peter eriksson científico del instituto
del medio ambiente de estocolmo pero
claro el estado de bienestar más grande
del mundo también hay que pagarlo
nosotros como país somos petroleros
dependemos tanto de los ingresos del
petróleo que al igual que los
alcohólicos queremos parar pero no
sabemos cómo tomás nielsen editor del
observatorio independiente de bárents
esto no quiere decir que noruega sea
como otros países en los que solo hay
petróleo para nada el país tiene cierta
dependencia pero ni punto de comparación
con por ejemplo venezuela o arabia
saudita aquí en noruega las cosas son
muy distintas entre otras cosas porque
aunque el gobierno tiene mucho peso en
la economía algo más del 50 por ciento
del pib ha procurado ser un país abierto
a los negocios y también a aprovechar
todo este dinero procedente del petróleo
para impulsar actividades productivas
lograr una educación de mucha calidad y
también ahorrar
el fondo de fondos lo cierto es que para
ser un país que ha hecho tanto dinero
con el petróleo es muy distinto a lo que
estamos acostumbrados
oslo la capital de noruega no está
plagada de rascacielos ni de gigantescos
centros comerciales ni de extravagantes
construcciones financiadas por el oro
negro en otras palabras puede que hayan
gastado mucho pero probablemente la gran
clave del éxito de noruega es no haber
derrochado como se han hecho muchos
otros países aquí el gobierno decidió
muy pronto ahorrar una buena parte de
los ingresos procedentes de los recursos
naturales y no se les ocurrió nada mejor
que crear un gran fondo soberano para
invertir la riqueza generada comprando
activos por todo el mundo
ojo porque estamos hablando del mayor
fondo soberano del planeta ni siquiera
países como arabia saudita o kuwait
tienen tantos ahorros fijaos el fondo
soberano de noruega alcanza un
patrimonio de un billón de dólares un
billón de dólares ojo esto equivale a
una fortuna ahorrada por el gobierno de
casi 190 mil dólares estadounidenses por
habitante y es que los noruegos en vez
de gastarse el dinero del petróleo a lo
loco decidieron invertir su dinero en
empresas de todo el mundo hoy este fondo
tiene dinero invertido en más de 9 mil
empresas de 78 países diferentes entre
ellas algunas tan conocidas como apple
nestlé cel o alphabet es decir google si
podríamos decir que el gobierno noruego
es propietario de una parte de youtube y
sabéis que uno de los objetivos de este
fondo es poder llegar a sustituir los
ingresos que genera el petróleo me
explico como os podéis imaginar las
inversiones generan beneficios pues bien
desde que se creó este gran fondo la
rentabilidad
media anual ha sido del 57 por ciento
así que sí por ejemplo esta rentabilidad
se mantuviese en el tiempo de media cada
año noruega obtendría más de 50 mil
millones de dólares en beneficios el
equivalente a una cuarta parte de todo
su gasto público no está mal verdad a
todo esto claro hay que sumarle los
ingresos que cada año el gobierno
obtiene del petróleo y también de muchas
empresas locales y aunque son públicas
funcionan con criterios de mercado
vamos que casi podríamos decir que
noruega no tiene mucho de qué
preocuparse verdad no es esperar un
momento porque a pesar de que el nivel
de bienestar parece que tiene pilares
sólidos el gobierno del país está
empeñado en lograr diversificar su
economía y hacerla más competitiva para
perder esta dependencia que todavía
tienen del petróleo
[Música]
las reformas
desde 1927 el partido laborista de
centroizquierda ha sido el partido más
votado en todas las elecciones generales
de noruega pero aquí las mayorías
absolutas no son algo común en 2013 una
coalición de partidos de centroderecha
entre ellos el polémico partido del
progresó que es conocido por sus
posiciones radicales en materia de
inmigración logró ocupar como primera
ministra a erna solberg hoy se la conoce
como la merkel noruega recientemente las
elecciones del pasado 11 de septiembre
de 2017 esta coalición fue reelegida la
intención de este gobierno amigos es
como decirlo distanciarse de algún modo
de lo que ha sido conocido como el
modelo noruego este gobierno quiere
mejorar la competitividad del país
reduciendo impuestos especialmente a las
empresas e impulsando la inversión tanto
la pública como la privada es así como
hemos visto también apuesta claramente
por seguir desarrollando la industria
del petróleo en cualquier caso sí
tienen claro noruega es que el
crecimiento el desarrollo y la
innovación son las mejores fórmulas para
conseguir bienestar y también mejorar el
cuidado del medio ambiente
[Música]
pero en fin turno para ti
crees que noruega es un modelo para la
gestión de los recursos naturales
déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y también en esta encuesta si te ha
gustado el vídeo
dale like y no olvides suscribirte a
visual político un saludo y hasta la
próxima pero no os vayáis todavía porque
me queda una cosa muy importante que
contaros este sábado 14 de octubre de
2017 voy a dar una charla en praga en
república checa y de que voy a hablar os
preguntaréis pues voy a hablar de todos
esos países africanos que están saliendo
de la pobreza así que ya sabéis si vivís
en praga o por alguna casualidad de la
vida vais a pasar este fin de semana en
república checa ya sabéis donde me
podéis encontrar en el instituto chevron
que está en la calle y un mano va 17 en
praga 1 es un evento que organiza la
asociación students por liberty así que
si queréis más detalles no tenéis más
que
en la siguiente página web fl conference
es punto o hereje os espero a todos por
ahí y como decimos por estas piedras y
viví meses
[Música]
[Aplausos]